et je suis avec le lieutenant colonel
sébastien frémont bonjour bonjour qui
est depuis new york où il va suivre donc
les 20 ans de ces commémorations des
attentats du 11 septembre on le rappelle
le 11 septembre 2001 quatre attentats
suicide qui avaient fait 2009 177
victimes
343 sapeurs pompiers dans la ville de
new york un touché sur les tours du
world trade center déjà tous les deux
ans sébastien frémont vous participez à
aux commémorations du 11-septembre vous
avez même créé une association dont on
va parler dans un instant pourquoi ça
vous tient à coeur de retourner sur
place et de participer à ces
commémorations en fait j'y participe
tous les ans depuis 2002 je n'en ai
loupé qu'une malheureusement à ce jour
qui est celle des de l'année dernière
compte tenu de la pandémie où on ne
pouvait pas se rendre à new york même
cette année au demeurant il a fallu que
nous fassions une mission officielle
pour pouvoir nous y rendre parce que ça
n'était pas imaginable
c'était pas concevoir pour ce qui nous
concerne ne pas pouvoir assister
particulièrement cette année à
l'occasion du 20e anniversaire des
attentats du 11-septembre et pas pouvoir
venir commémorer à côté de nos frères
d'armes cette année particulière donc
oui je viens à titre personnel depuis
2002 disait ge
et tout est parti d'une association que
nous avons créée au lendemain des
attentats dès le 12 septembre de
meilleur en réalité toi nous étions
trois collègues des yvelines qui avions
déjà des amis parmi des pompiers
américains et à new york en particulier
et par conséquent immédiatement s'était
mis à collecter de l'argent on ne savait
pas ce qu'on serait de cet argent mais
rapidement ça a débouché sur le souhaite
vouloir réaliser une opération du coeur
qui s'est concrétisée six mois plus tard
au mois de mars 2002 en faisant venir 53
membres de familles de pompiers en deuil
et donc des veuves des orphelins et puis
des membres des familles ne serait ce
que pour encadrer ces pauvres gens
pour les sortir finalement de leur
quotidien et de ce marasme et ils
vivaient et pour les accueillir au sein
des familles de pompiers des yvelines
l'idée c'était bel et bien comme je le
disais une opération du coeur on les a
hébergés dans nos familles et cette
association elle s'appelle fdn y est spé
soixante dix huit vous le dites vous
continuer de venir sur place et de vous
impliquer au sein de cette association
c'est important de s'impliquer sur le
long terme justement vous le dites et
ses victimes 343 il ya aussi des
conséquences à plus long terme de ces
attentats oui c'est d'autant plus
important de s'inscrire dans cette dure
et que malheureusement aujourd'hui 20
ans après le drame du 11 septembre 2001
on continue de mourir des conséquences
de cet attentat de ces attentats
tout simplement parce que les sauveteurs
les pompiers les policiers et toute
cette communauté de sauveteurs qui s'est
engagé sur les lieux pour tenter de
sauver un maximum de personnes qui se
trouvaient dans les tours par la suite
on continuer à y travailler d'abord pour
tenter de retrouver les victimes puis
pour déblayer le site ce qui fait que
pendant des semaines et des mois et ils
ont travaillé et il dit ont surtout
respirer des substances extrêmement
toxique l'air ambiant était composé de
deux métaux lourds y compris d'ailleurs
de substances radioactives parce qu'il
faut savoir que les tours jumelles la
technologie de l'époque des années 1970
en matière de détection d'un stand ea
chaque détecteur
contenait une source radioactive ce qui
fait que plusieurs années après certains
ont commencé à développer des maladies
des cancers des insuffisances
respiratoires et qui malheureusement au
fil des ans ont décimé leur rang ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui dans quelques jours
20 ans exactement
après le drame en ce qui concerne les
pompiers on déplore deux cent cinquante
six pompiers supplémentaires qui sont
morts en plus des 343 qui sont décédés
ce le jour même alors pour aussi ses 20
ans de ces commémorations du 11
septembre 2001 vous avez écrit un livre
avec marc le guélaff marque bida
frédéric arrou la préface est signée de
jules naudet qui était sur place qui est
l'un des rares à avoir eu des images sur
place puisqu'il était en train de
réaliser un documentaire à ce moment là
parlez nous de ce projet commence et il
monthey s'est il concrétiser et parler
aussi du contenu de celui il ya beaucoup
de photos notamment que vous avez
réalisé depuis vos nombreux voyages à
new york
c'est ça vous avez tout dit gregory
effectivement j'ai la chance que jules
naudet m'accorde son amitié et que par
conséquent il m'a également fait
confiance pour accepter non seulement
pour effacer cet ouvrage mais finalement
topé chose de beaucoup plus important
qui est une exclusivité de ce livre est
finalement le coeur et l'âme de cet
ouvrage il a il a accepté de me raconter
son septembre
ainsi que les jours et les années qui
ont suivi
jules étant bien sûr lui même un
survivant ayant eu la chance de ne pas
être blessé physiquement en revanche a
été blessé les blessures de l'âme ça se
mesurent moins bien c'est moins
mesurable pour autant les sont bien
réels et ça a été compliqué de sortir de
ce syndrome du survivant
et donc il m'a accordé sa confiance pour
me raconter tout ça ce qui a permis d'en
écrire un chapitre complet
dans cet ouvrage donc c'est vraiment
l'art du livre à côté de cela
effectivement il ya c'est un livre
d'image malgré ce texte important dans
le chapitre qui est consacrée à jules
mais sinon c'est principalement on
revient sur les 20 ans qui se sont
écoulés sur les cérémonies comme je le
disais en effet auquel je participe
pratiquement tous les ans sur
l'évolution des pompiers de new york
puisque sirleaf qui a orienté sur les
pompiers de new york ce sont les
pompiers de new york au travers la
tragédie dans septembre 2001 est donc
surtout vingt ans après et bien sûr un
autre aspect important du livre qui est
celui dont on vient de parler qui est le
fait que parmi leurs rangs on continue
de décéder des conséquences de cet
attentat donc les new york 11 septembre
2001 à 20 ans après 1 c'est le nom de
cet ouvrage une dernière question on
enregistre cet entretien le jeudi soir
puisque dès le vendredi vous serez dans
ces commémorations du 11 septembre 2001
qu'elle va être justement le programme
des commémorations à new york alors le
11 mai melon 70 samedi va être une
journée extrêmement charge extrêmement
lourde en émotions mais pour ce qui nous
concerne elle commencera de bonheur dès
7 heures du matin heure locale c'est à
dire 13 heures pour vous par une
première cérémonie officielle qui va se
donner se tenir au monument des pompiers
de new york
sur le nord ouest de manhattan non loin
de l'aude sonne la rivière hudson puis
elle se poursuivre au sein des casernes
donc certains d'entre nous il est en
désaccord
qui à brooklyn qui sur manhattan en ce
qui me concerne j'ai membres et une
caserne dont je suis proche à brooklyn
pour y observer la première minute de
silence à 8h46 soit 14h46 heure de paris
vont s'enchaîner les différentes minute
de silence correspondant aux différents
moments marquants les impacts des avions
l'effondrement des tours etc le
pentagone ce 3 p
et tout ça pour aller jusqu'à la fin de
matinée est allé jusqu'au début d'après
midi ou à 13h30 se tiendra la cérémonie
officielle pour les pompiers de new york
pour le fbi a noyé le fire department of
new york en la cathédrale saint patrick
une cérémonie sur la 5e avenue à
laquelle la délégation des pompiers des
yvelines est convié à l'invitation des
pompiers de new york semble très très
honoré et
pour finir la journée au niveau du
mémorial du 11-septembre donc cette fois
ci sur le site même du world trade
center où se sont déroulés les attentats
pour devant la caserne numéro 10 qui se
trouve désormais face à ce mémorial et
qui était au pied des tours jumelles une
performance des de la formation musicale
des pompiers de new york avec
principalement des cornemuses qui
entameront notamment amazing grace
la mémoire de leurs morts au même moment
où la nuit va tomber et que les tours de
lumière tous les biotine lie les deux
les deux tours illuminé de bleu qui
symbolisent les deux tours jumelles
désormais disparu vont s'illuminer au
moment où la nuit bâtir sa future a7
cette journée extrêmement dense mais
surtout forte en émotions et sévir sur
la raison pour laquelle nous tenons
absolument être aux côtés de nos de nos
amis américains et tout particulièrement
de nos frères d'armes pompiers de new
york merci colonel sébastien frémont
depuis new york d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle pompiers des yvelines également
chef de prévention aux 10 78 merci
d'avoir été avec nous je vous en prie